hi schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid bei
ZDF heute live vielleicht habt ihr schon
Bilder oder Videos der Aktionen heute
irgendwo im Internet genäht gesehen die
sogenannte letzte Generation hat heute
versucht mit rund 35 Blockaden die
Hauptstadt Berlin lahm zu legen da
standen dann Menschen auf der Straße
blockierten diese mit Autos oder klebten
sich das ist ja mittlerweile sowas wie
das Markenzeichen der Gruppe mit Kleber
auf die Straße ja im Rahmen dieser
Protestaktion wurden das ist der Stand
von heute Nachmittag laut Berliner
innensenatorin rund 200 Personen an 35
Orten festgenommen die sogenannte letzte
Generation fordert mit ihren
Protestaktionen ja immer wieder
konsequentere Maßnahmen für den
Klimaschutz von der Bundesregierung wie
legitim dieser Protest ist dazu gehen
die Meinung aktuell aufeinander
ich habe für Anliegen Verständnis aber
für die Art und Weise überhaupt nicht es
geht nicht an dass irgendwelche selbst
ananten Weltretter glauben den deutschen
starterpressen zu dürfen
bei den Politikern vor fort Büro setzen
oder nicht wir befinden uns im zivilen
friedlichen Widerstand und protestieren
gegen das fossile waren diesen fossilen
Wahnsinn in die Bundesregierung
weitermacht sie treibt uns damit Sehnen
Augen ist in die Klimakatastrophe das
Zeitfenster in dem wir eine Katastrophe
den Kollaps unserer Gesellschaft noch
abwenden können das schließlich wenn ich
von Katastrophe spreche dann spreche ich
davon dass unsere ernten ausfallen
werden dann spricht davon dass das
Wasser knapp wird
ja wir hören von Argumenten auf der
Aktivistin Seite wir hören aber auch von
Argumenten von den Menschen die da im
Stau stehen und genervt sind und über
diese Proteste über die deutschen
Klimaziele und überhaupt über die grüne
Politik der Bundesregierung wollen wir
gleich sprechen mit Rafael telen er ist
Aktivist bei der sogenannten letzten
Generation und mit Stefan Geld hat er
ist Bundestagsabgeordneter und
verkehrspolitischer Sprecher von Bündnis
90 die Grünen im Bundestag und wie immer
will ich darüber auch mit euch da
draußen sprechen habt ihr Fragen zum
Thema oder wollt einfach mal eure
Meinung mit uns teilen dann macht das
gerne hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail
an die Mail-Adresse die ihr da gerade
eingeblendet seht damit wir alle auf dem
gleichen Stand sind lasst uns noch mal
einen Blick darauf werfen was da genau
heute in Berlin alles passiert ist
los geht's früh am Morgen etwa am
Ernst-Reuter-Platz Bezirk Charlottenburg
oder auf der Stadtautobahn egal wo
überall ein ähnliches Bild nur wenige
Aktivisten und viele viele Autos im Stau
die Polizei spricht von rund 35
Protestaktionen überall in der
Hauptstadt je eine Auswahl der größten
man klebt am Fleck deswegen kommen
Rettungswagen teils nicht durch wohl
auch weil keine Rettungsgasse gebildet
wird
viele Autofahrer reagieren wütend und
versuchen sich Platz zu schaffen selbst
Justiz mit allen Mitteln auch mit
drastischen dieser Mann zieht Frauen von
der Straße an den Haaren
etwa 500 Einsatzkräfte sind vor Ort sie
lösen die meisten Aktionen schon am
frühen Nachmittag auf und nehmen mehr
als 200 Menschen fest 50 von ihnen
kommen in Gewahrsam damit sie nicht
umgehend wieder protestieren auf den
Straßen Berlins
ja über diesen Protest und die
Klimapolitik der Ampel sprechen wir
jetzt mit Raphael Themen von der letzten
Generation und Stefan gell paar vom
Bündnis 90 die Grünen herzlich
willkommen schön dass Sie bei uns sind
guten Abend
Herr telen wir fangen mal direkt mit
Ihnen an die sind ja selber Aktivist bei
der sogenannten letzten Generation wie
bewerten die denn den heutigen Tag in
Berlin war das aus ihrer sichten Erfolg
klar wenn man sich anschaut wo wir
angefangen haben von einem Jahr vor
anderthalb Jahren war das in Dutzend
Menschen und selbst im Herbst war nicht
so viele und jetzt waren
300 200 Leute auf der Straße 35
Blockaden sie haben es eben gezeigt
ist mal wieder genötigt nicht mit dem
Thema auseinanderzusetzen dass sie sehr
sehr gerne vermeiden würden und es geht
natürlich für die FDP natürlich für die
SPD leider auch für die Grünen weil
meine grüne natürlich da müssen auch
sparen kann aber natürlich war das so
gesehen ein Erfolg
sie sind ja Teil vom Bündnis 90 die
Grünen das ist also sowas wie die
klimapartei im deutschen Volks und wie
guckt man in ihrer Partei jetzt auf
diesen Protesttag weil
Klimaziele oder engagierte Klimaschutz
das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Interesse
ihrer Partei oder
also engagierter Klimaschutz klar das
ist nicht nur Interesse unserer Partei
das ist quasi die DNA unserer Partei und
tatsächlicherweise nehmen wir natürlich
diese Proteste war das ist klar wir
sehen auch die ja immer wieder geäußerte
Verzweiflung der AktivistInnen
Aktivisten dass das wollen wir auch gar
nicht wegdiskutieren
ob das jetzt den Klimaschutz Gedanken in
die Breite der Gesellschaft in die
Breite der Politik transportiert oder ob
wir immer stärker über Selbstjustiz über
ja
Protestformen diskutieren das glaube ich
da kann man sehr geteilter Meinung sein
wir sehen jetzt nicht dass heute mit
diesem Tag der klimaschutzten Schritt
nach vorne gekommen ist sondern ich
persönlich sehe immer Menschen die
genervt sind und wir müssen ja dahin
kommen dass man nicht nur auf die
Klimakrise aufmerksam macht ich glaube
das Passwort Klimakrise das ist zwischen
jedem geläufig sondern dass wir die
Klima Saboteure die eben den aktiven
klimaschutzenden effektiven Klimaschutz
stören oder behindern dass wir die
stellen und ich glaube da müssen wir in
auch
zivilgesellschaftlich in den
Aktionsformen deutlich präziser werden
ja wir merken schon das sind zwei
ziemlich unterschiedliche Sichtweisen
auf ein und denselben Tag obwohl das ja
Herr gelber hat gerade gesagt eigentlich
auch die DNA der Grünen ist den
Klimaschutz voranzutreiben ja
seid die Grünen in der Ampel auf
Bundesebene regieren mussten sie bei
diesem DNA Thema allerdings ein paar
Kompromisse eingehen lass uns da mal
drauf gucken
2022 wurden die Klimaziele in
Deutschland teilweise verfehlt zu diesem
Ergebnis kam der Expertenrat für
Klimafragen in einem jährlichen
Prüfbericht eigentlich dass wir in
keinem Sektor wirklich auf einem guten
Weg sind und das heißt auch wenn wir
aggregiert betrachten ist es nicht so
dass ein Sektor dem anderen was
ausleihen könnte vor allem in den
Bereichen Gebäude und Verkehr sind
Emissionen weiterhin zu hoch insgesamt
gingen die umweltschädlichen Emissionen
2022 gegenüber 2021 zwar um 1,9 % zurück
das lag aber vor allem an der Industrie
sie produzierte während der
corona-pandemie weniger Emissionen im
Verkehrssektor fordern Klimaschützer
mehr Engagement im Wahlprogramm der
Grünen vor der Bundestagswahl hieß es
noch Deutschland hat keinen Mangel an
Straßen erst recht keinen ein Autobahnen
wir wollen deshalb den
bundesverkehrswege Plan schnellstmöglich
durch einen neuen Bundesnetzplan
ersetzen
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing von der
FDP hält am Individualverkehr mit Auto
nicht nur fest erfordert sogar den
Ausbau von 144 Autobahnen Projekten auch
ein flächendeckendes Tempolimit wird
innerhalb der Koalition heftig
diskutiert die Grünen fordern einen
Tempolimit von 130 km/h auf Autobahnen
die FDP ist dagegen eine Studie des
Bundesumweltministeriums kam zu dem
Ergebnis dass mit einem flächendeckenden
Tempolimit von 130 km/h jährlich bis zu
1,9 Millionen Tonnen CO2 eingespart
werden könnten andere Berechnungen sehen
neben dem Klimaschutzeffekt auch ein
erheblichen wirtschaftlichen Nutzen bei
einem Tempolimit unter anderem durch
eingesparten Treibstoff und weniger
Unfällen
ja noch mal als Kontext für euch
Deutschland will seinen treibhausausstoß
bis 2030 um 65 Prozent gegenüber 1990
reduzieren und bis 2045 soll sogar
Klimaneutralität erreicht werden dort
Expertenrat ist dieses Klimaziel aber
nicht zu erreichen wenn es in diesem
Tempo weitergeht und diese Sektor Ziele
von denen wir gerade gehört haben da
wurde letztens nach einem
Koalitionsausschuss verkündet dass diese
sektorziele aufgehoben werden sollen das
heißt es wird über den
durchschnittsemissionswert über alle
Sektoren hinweg geguckt also das heißt
jeder Sektor ein Sektor muss jetzt nicht
mehr einen bestimmtes Ziel erreichen
sondern alle gemeinsam müssen das Ziel
erreichen Herr gab würden Sie sagen die
Grünen sind immer noch eine klimapartei
warum merkt man denn da auf Bundesebene
gerade so wenig von also ich glaube
viele Menschen sehen das schon die
Entwicklung nach 16 Jahren quasi Agonie
und Stillstand haben wir jetzt im
Bereich Landwirtschaft im Bereich
Energiewende aber auch im Bereich Umwelt
schon deutsche Schritte nach vorne
gemacht selbst im Bereich Verkehr der so
gescheiten ist gibt es Hoffnung bei
aller Düsternis des 49 € Tickets in
aller Munde ist Verbrenner ausgesetzt
beschlossen das heißt mein anderen
Worten der Hochlauf der Elektromobilität
ähm wir haben das Homeoffice gestärkt
bzw sind da noch weg das noch weiter zu
machen wir haben Milliarden Paket für
Bus und Bahn geschmiert das reicht alles
nicht das ist vollkommen klar und
natürlich müssen wir da auch den
Verkehrsminister antreiben damit da ja
die Verkehrswende kommt und da ist viel
zu tun und an diesem viel zu tun
der wäre natürlich leichter wenn man
statt 15% im Bundestag 25 hätten ist
jetzt aber nicht so deswegen müssen wir
dem arbeiten was wir haben das tun wir
Tag für Tag legen uns damit der
Opposition aber eben auch das ein oder
andere Mal mit unserem geliebten
Koalitionspartner an um eben den
Klimaschutz voranzubringen
das ist nicht immer schön und nicht
immer einfach und das sieht man ja auch
das wird ja auch bereit berichtet in der
Presse das ist da Stress gibt das ist
der Streit gibt aber tatsächlicherweise
parlamentarische Mehrheiten und
gesellschaftliche Mehrheiten fallen
beide nicht vom Himmel sondern müssen im
mühsam hergestellten arbeitet werden
manchmal mit Verhandlung ja das ist so
also
muss ich ja mal vorstellen wir haben ja
keine 51 Prozent im Bundestag dann
würden wir nur mit uns selbst verhandeln
sondern wir müssen gucken wie weit die
Gesetze so hinbekommen dass wir eben
auch die Zustimmung von SPD und FDP
bekommen da haperts hier und dort das
ist voll auch ein Beitrag gerade raus
ist jetzt nicht so dass der die Sektoren
Ziele oder die mich nennst lieber
Verpflichtungen aus dem Sektoren dass
die jetzt mit einmal wechseln sind
sondern es kommt eine
sektorübergreifende Betrachtung dazu und
im Kern sollen die sektorziele erhalten
werden da müssen wir schauen wie wir
diese Verpflichtungen dann im Gesetz so
Scharfstellen dass es zum Beispiel auch
den Ansprüchen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts genügt und
eben auch den Pariser Klimaschutzzielen
das wird noch eine spannende Verhandlung
die wir da mit SPD und FDP zu führen
haben
ja man hört von vielen Kompromissen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen von der
Ernüchterung in diesem politischen
Tagesbetrieb Herren sie sind Teil der
letzten Generation und eine erklärt das
Ziel von ihnen ist ja auch ein oder war
ein 9 € Ticket her spricht gerade an
jetzt kommt das 49 € Ticket wie
zufrieden sind Sie denn mit dem was die
Grünen bisher in der Ampel
klimaschutztechnisch erreichen
naja erstmal sagen genau ist ja ein
Erfolg von uns es wird immer gesagt das
bringt nicht was wir tun aber jetzt
kommt dieses Ticket nicht für 9 Euro
aber für 49 Euro wie gesagt das Thema
ist jeden Tag in den Medien weil wir
darauf hinweisen es gibt mittlerweile
Bundesländern in denen wird über ein
Lebensmittel rettengesetz verhandelt so
wie wir das ursprünglich auch mal
gefordert haben aber man muss sich immer
wieder klar machen uns geht's ja nicht
um Klimaschutzziele sondern unsere
Lebensgrundlagen zu schützen wir haben
ich habe für die letzten vier fünf Jahre
für den Spiegel und die Zeit über den
Klimakrise berichtet ich war in
Südafrika mit der Familie geredet in
Kapstadt in der Stadt ziemlich ähnlich
wie Berlin und diese Familie mit fünf
Personen hatte 25 Liter Wasser am Tag
sind 5 Liter pro Person das reicht kaum
zu trinken kaum zu kochen und nicht zum
Waschen und kapstadt ist sehr ähnlich
wie Berlin Deutschland ist am härtesten
betroffenen Regionen der Klimakrise das
Mittelmeer ist eine dem Herzen
Betroffenen Krisen Regionen
wir müssen uns klar machen es geht hier
nicht um Klimaschutzziele es geht nicht
immer mit der Zahlen es geht nicht um
das Paris Abkommen natürlich müssen wir
das Einhalten wir haben uns dazu
verpflichtet aber es geht um unsere
Lebensgrundlagen und dann muss man sich
vielleicht auch mal durchsetzen und das
müssen wir uns immer mal wieder klar
machen das ist das worüber wir hier
reden wir reden nicht über irgendwas was
wir tun können sondern wenn wir das
nicht machen dann sagen Menschen die
Stefan Rahmsdorf
schellenhuber unsere bedeutendsten
Klimaforscher das unsere Existenz
Existenz unserer Zivilisation bedroht
ist und das bedeutet Bürgerkriege Hunger
Durst Zusammenbruch und darüber müssen
wir reden und dann kommt bei den Grünen
leider doch ein bisschen viel waschen
rüber also ich mein Denken über letzter
Rad nach das war nicht die FDP das war
nicht die SPD
die Kohle da rausholen kann unter
falschen vorwenden sondern die Grünen
ähm sie sind ja Teil der Ampelkoalition
mit den Grünen und sie sind nicht
unbedingt der kleinste Junior-Partner
bei Herr Thielen gibt's da viel
Unverständnis warum quasi gerade viele
Kompromisse in Richtung FTP gefunden
werden können Sie diese diese Wut ich
spreche jetzt einfach mal von Wut können
Sie die verstehen
natürlich kann ich
das verstehen das nachvollziehen das ist
jetzt intellektuell jetzt nicht so
herausfordernd zu sagen das reicht nicht
weil es genau diesen Punkt der trägt uns
ja durch den Tag uns Bündnis grüne weil
wir machen ja nichts anderes wir stehen
morgen auch morgens auf und fangen dann
an zu arbeiten unsere Lebensgrundlagen
zu erhalten im klimaschutzbereichen
Umweltschutzbereich und so weiter und so
weiter
um diesen Kriegen diesen Krisen eben
adäquat zu begegnen das ist das weshalb
wir Politik machen dass das treibt uns
an und das ist glaube ich auch die
Verbindung zu Aktivistinnen und
Aktivisten der Klima Bewegung wir haben
jetzt immer die Suche nach dem richtigen
Hebel um trotz 15 % im Bundestag eben 51
% für eingesetzten zu bekommen so und ja
da müssen wir dann eben auch mal schauen
was was ist da ist narrativ richtig was
ist was stimmt und was stimmt nicht
z.brad ist jetzt nicht verteidigen ich
finde es auch nicht schön dass dieses
Dorf jetzt da zerstört wird und
abgebaggert wird ich finde sogar falsch
aber muss feststellen dass stand schon
vor der Koalitionen im Gesetz drinne und
in den Koalitionsverhandlungen konnten
wir dort jeder bei SPD noch bei FDP ein
Verständnis dafür finden mehr als diese
fünf Dörfer also kein Burg unter Estrich
oberestrich zu retten deswegen haben wir
die fünf Orte retten können aber den
sechsten eben nicht und das ist schlecht
das ist
[Musik]
ja so und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
trotzdem aufstehen und weitermachen so
das ist
wir werden diesen Kampf wäre noch mal
kämpfen müssen um Osten der Republik wo
wir noch keinen Kohleausstieg 2035 haben
so einen wo noch viel weitere Landschaft
Fläche Räume bedroht sind wo noch so na
ich will es jetzt gar nicht schwarz
meinte der aber die also Macht kommen
wir müssen ins machen kommen
die verursache dieser Krise sprechen
dabei gibt es in Deutschland eine sehr
klare Verteilung der sehr viele
Emissionen produziert das oberste sind
die obersten zehn Prozent in Deutschland
produziert 150 Tonnen CO2 im Jahr es ist
zehnmal so viel wie ich und wenn man
noch in das oberste Prozent reingeht
dann sind das bis zu 11.000 Tonnen das
ist tausend mal so viel CO2 wie ich im
Jahr produziere warum gehen sie nicht
dahin warum müssen
die zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung die
unteren zwei Drittel die letzten 40
Jahren ihre Emissionen schon gesenkt
haben warum müssen die jetzt auf die
Heizungen tauschen warum geht's nicht
mal dahin wo die wirklich großen
Verschmutzung sind warum gehen sie nicht
meine RWE dran rWE ist reich geworden
mit der Produktion dieser Klimakrise da
sind die sitzen auch sehr sehr viel Geld
das Geld dafür vielleicht brauchen
könnten um die Transformation zu
bezahlen kein reicher muss da haben wenn
wir ihm seine Flüge streichen kein
Mensch braucht eine riesige Villa das
sind doch alles Themen die wir mal
ansprechen könnten stattdessen hacken
wir uns einen kleinen es geht um
Gerechtigkeit in dieser Krise es gibt
Menschen die Krise verursacht und es
gibt Menschen die leiden unter dieser
Krise und darüber müssen wir reden und
nicht über 1000 kleine Ausschüsse ich
meine wir haben doch hier ein großes
gesellschaftliches Problem wo sind
angemessen ist
also zum einen sind wir jetzt in der
Analyse da würde ich ihn sogar zustimmen
dass dort gute Silvester Menschen gibt
die wir besonders adressieren müssen
weil dort der CO2-Ausstoß oder der
Treibhausgas Ausstoß besonders hoch ist
ich sage aber zum einen wir müssen alle
Menschen adressieren so und zu zweiten
wenn wenn Sie das so sagen und wir dann
Analyse gleich oder ähnlich sind dann
frage ich mich aber auch wie wir dann
mit der
Blockade einer ganzen Stadt gerade auch
einer Stadt die jetzt nicht zu den
reichsten in Deutschland gehört wo wo
denn da dann der richtige Punkt der
richtige Hilfe gefunden ist es geht
nicht um Analyse das sage ich nochmal
die Klimakrise ist für sie wie für mich
vollkommen klar vollkommen präsent wir
müssen dagegen anarbeiten so und wenn
man das haben dann geht's doch nicht
mehr darum zu analysieren auch weiter
die Analyse haben dass wir eigentlich
bei also wir wollen ja das Leben für die
Menschen nicht schwer machen wir wollen
die Lebensgrundlagen erhalten damit sie
künftig eben weiterhin gutes Leben
führen können so und jetzt müssen wir
wieder Verkehr
spolitisch sprechen sie sollten auch
wissen dass die paar Staus die wir hin
und wieder produzieren den Witz sind
gegen das was am Staus jeden Tag in
Deutschland passiert also Berlin wird
ständig für Marathon gesperrt oder für
ein großes Event und dann mault auch
keiner rum also das was wir da machen
ist doch
Witz und natürlich wollen wir niemanden
blockieren also ich ich habe vor einem
Jahr ein Video gesehen Bauarbeiter
springt aus seinem Auto rennt auf die
Blockaden zu ich keine Zeit ich habe
kein Geld wegen Corona sind für alle
Pleite mein Vater war genauso und
Bauarbeiter nie Geld nie Zeit kleine
Firma und ich dachte scheiße und
trotzdem sitze ich jetzt Entschuldigung
trotzdem sitze ich jetzt da mit der
letzten Generation weil wir über
Gerechtigkeit sprechen müssen und weil
wir Druck machen müssen und leider ist
es halt so das große gesellschaftliche
Veränderungen sehr oft über Druck auf
der Straße passiert sind denken die
Frauenrechte denken Sie an die rechte
schwarzer Menschen in den USA sind immer
motivieren Ungehorsam passiert und ja
das ist doof ich will niemanden sitzt
gerne
hier Einschalten
zum Thema Mehrheiten bilden und zum
Thema Legitimation dieser Protestform
das ist ja das Thema um das gerade so
ein bisschen geht und es ist eine Frage
an Sie erzählen das ZDF Politbarometer
hat ergeben dass insgesamt 80% der da
befragten Menschen finden das illegale
Aktion von klimaaktivisten wie Ihnen
also wie die Blockaden von Hauptverkehr
Straßen zu weit gehen und hier schreibt
auch gerade jemand aus der Community
eine konkrete Frage an Sie die lautet
von innen ist Sokolowski auf Youtube
wäre es nicht klüger sich vor einem
Kohlekraftwerk zu kleben oder raffiner
raffinerin zu boykottieren ich denke die
Autofahrer können da wenig dafür
super Frage danke also zu kurz zu der
Zahl mit den 80%. diese Zahl stimmt aber
mittlerweile sagen wir auch 55 Prozent
dass doch die Bürgermeister und
BürgermeisterInnen verschiedener Städte
mit uns verhandeln sollen also
offensichtlich kommt da was in Bewegung
und ja was die Kraftwerke angeht das
machen wir auch und das haben wir auch
probiert wir haben uns zum Beispiel an
die Ölpipelines geklebt und gekettet die
Öl aus Russland nach Deutschland
gebracht haben nur leider hat kein
Medium darüber berichtet es wurde x-mal
gemacht die Leute das gemacht haben
haben hohe Strafen riskiert und es hat
einfach keine Resonanz gefunden und
leider wenn wir uns in den Verkehr
reinkleben und zu diesem Konflikt kommen
mit Autofahrern und Autofahrerin dann
gibt's immer den großen aufschreiben
plötzlich werden wir hier abends
eingeladen und können über unser
Anliegen schwächen den Schutz unserer
Lebensgrundlagen der von unserer
Regierung missachtet wird und dann sind
für ich mich doch einfach hilflos also
noch mal ich habe mir vier Jahre lang
als Reporter in Südafrika im Irak in der
Arktis im A3 angeguckt dass die Folgen
der Klimakrise sind ich habe diesen Job
aufgegeben Freunde gemacht hat und setze
mich jetzt auf die Straße und ich würde
das nicht tun wenn ich was besseres
wüsste was ich machen könnte
wir haben hier noch eine Frage die
speziell an sie geht von Fabian Harms
auf Youtube der fragt sie reden ja
gerade den zivilen Ungehorsam heilig
würden sie es auch gut finden wenn ich
mich auf die Straße klebe wenn ich gegen
ein Tempolimit bin
ich für eine gute Sache wenn sie ihn
Anliegen haben dass
moralisch rational irgendwie gut zu
begründen ist
und da finde ich zum Beispiel immer und
das ein bisschen hochgestochen aber
kannst kategorischen Imperativ kurz
gefasst dass du möchtest das allgemein
besetzt werden könnte wenn du das Gefühl
hast wenn Sie das Gefühl haben ja kein
Verkehr kein Problem
können klar machen ich glaube das hilft
nicht wir haben es eben in dem einen
Spieler gesehen
wurde hohe
Temperaturen zu mehr CO2 Ausstoß zu mehr
Feinstaubbelastung und und und und und
und aber natürlich und sie wieder auch
vom Verfassungsgericht bedeckt also in
jeder Demokratie gibt es das ist
schlichtweg erlaubt es ist eine Straftat
aber eine bewusste Straftat um etwas
halt falsch läuft
erzählen sie wollten das Wort ergreifen
jetzt haben sie glaube ich ich bin ja
gelber Entschuldigung also ziviler
Ungehorsam ist erlaubt es stimmt
Straftaten sind es nicht sonst würden
sie nicht Straftaten heißen natürlich
muss die Polizei dann wiederum
verhältnismäßig agieren natürlich darf
es nicht dazu kommen dass Bürgerinnen
und Bürger da aus selbstjustizgründen
auf andere Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
rennen und die da verletzten oder
misshandeln so das heißt wir sind da
einer virulenten einer schwierigen
Stelle in unserem Rechtsstaat in unserer
Demokratie da ist was erlaubt das nervt
ärgert andere das wird genutzt umgehen
auch mit so einem bitte zu demonstrieren
und dann müssen beide Seiten trotzdem da
ein Stück weit Maß und bitte halten
damit man dann eben auch danach nach der
Aktion noch zusammen weiter in der
gleichen Stadt leben kann ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig und ich sage auch immer
dazu öffentlich Druck zu machen um auf
ein Thema aufmerksam zu machen das ist
total richtig und total wichtig man muss
dann auch ehrlich bleiben natürlich
hätte ihn wollen sie blockieren sonst
würden sie ja nicht eine Blockade auf
einer Straße machen das sollte man dann
auch so sagen das ist ja per se auch
jetzt erstmal nicht verboten das haben
sie beschrieben ob das in jeder Stelle
schlau ist ist wiederum eine andere
Frage wir müssen gucken und finden Suche
nach den Hebeln um mehr Klimaschutz um
Erhaltung unserer Lebensgrundlage jeden
Tag ein Stück mehr zu verwirklichen da
wissen sie haben
tatsächlich die Grünen als ersten
Partner natürlich also ich ich sehe sie
nicht als als auch im anderen Spektrum
ich sehe ich glaube auch dass sie das
absolut ernst meinen ähm die
Lebensgrundlage schützen zu wollen ist
halt immer eine Frage von Tempo von
Durchsetzungskraft und und und und und
und und ja genau und da fängt dann halt
an z.B so so eine parlamentarische
Mehrheit fürs Tempolimit hätte ich gerne
habe ich nicht sondern da ist jetzt die
spannende Frage wie kriegen wir das hin
dass eine FDP oder meinetwegen auch eine
CDU ähm da ist eine andere Einschätzung
der Lage kommt wann wird diese Dramatik
der Klimakrise auch in diesen Kreisen
innerhalb der anderen Parteien bewusst
wann kommt es dazu den Gedanken okay
Klimakrise Klimaschutz Haltung unserer
Lebensgrundlage ist jetzt kein nice to
have sondern ist ein must do so und da
sind wir ähm auf dem
sehr steinigen Weg unterwegs war das ist
eben gerade kein Selbstläufer überhaupt
nicht bloß einzuerkennen dass es sowas
wie ein Klimawandel gibt heißt doch noch
nicht ansatzweise zu akzeptieren dass
man dann auch ins Handeln kommen muss
und deswegen dann ja bitte nein also
wirklich verstanden
Christian Lindner hat die Klimakrise
bloß nicht verstanden und hätte er das
verstanden würde er handeln ich glaube
er es geht darum dass du Menschen die
Matthias Döpfner der Springer Besitzer
der Springer Verleger 1,3 Milliarden
besitzt dieser Mensch und der sagt die
Klima der Klimawandel sei gut
und dieser Matthias Döpfner fördert
Christian Lindner ganz bewusst so wie
sehr sehr viele sehr einflussreiche
große Konzerne in Deutschland und
deswegen macht Christian Lindner die
Politik die er macht deswegen macht ein
bisschen die Politik die er macht nicht
weil wir es nicht verstanden haben und
das müssen wir uns immer wieder
klarmachen es gibt Menschen die
profitieren von dieser Krise und es gibt
Menschen die darunter leiden und das
müssen wir uns klar machen
ich glaube bei Herrn Döpfner halt seit
ich also ich kenne ihn nicht ja deswegen
weiß ich nicht welchen Intelligenz
gerade er vor sich her trägt aber das
ist vielleicht die dümmste aufsage aus
seinem keine Ahnung was er sonst zu
erzählt dir so getan hat weil das
Deutschland versteckt dass man das
Spanien eben nicht mehr in Urlaub fährt
weiß da viel zu heiß ist auch so
überhaupt aus solchen Gedanken zu kommen
also dieses dieses
Europa quasi lost zu lassen oder werden
zu lassen wenn das wirklich aus seiner
Perspektive eine gute Wahl ist eine gute
Richtung ist ja dann ist der Mann
einfach los aber das ist jetzt nicht
aufhalten sondern wir müssen dann an ihm
vorbei gegen ihn und wenn vielleicht
gibt's ja auch ein buchungspunkt wo man
auch mit ihm arbeiten kann da eben diese
Klimakrise bekämpfen um unsere
Lebensgrundlagen zu halten und nochmal
zurück beim Tempolimit haben wir aktuell
wenn man das jetzt morgen im Bundestag
abstimmen lassen würden und alle es gäbe
keinen alle Abgeordneten würden das so
machen ihren vollständig in Gewissen
folgen dann weiß ich zumindest von dem
Programm der Parteien her dass ich da
nicht wahrscheinlich eine Zustimmung der
Linkspartei bis vielleicht auf ein zwei
Leute die Züchtung der SPD vielleicht
bist auch ein zwei Leute 100 % beim
grünen bekommen würde das würde aber
nicht reichen so und das muss man sich
glaube ich immer wieder bewusst machen
dass FDP CDU und AFD ganz klar sich
gegen den positionieren und das wenn es
da Menschen gibt innerhalb dieser
Parteien die das anders sehen dann
finden die irgendwie ihre Stimme dazu
nicht oder kriegen die Hand nicht hoch
oder beides
aber noch mal kurz einschalten alles gut
ja hier eine lebhafte Diskussion so soll
das ja auch sein noch mal zum Stichwort
demokratische Entscheidung wir leben in
einer parlamentarischen Demokratie und
oft braucht es für politische
Entscheidung und das braucht für
politische Entscheidung Mehrheiten und
es hat noch eine Nachricht erreicht
jetzt gerade live
Karl-heinz glühmann hat uns eine Mail
geschrieben in der er sagt die letzte
Generation hat keine Legitimation für
ihr radikales Vorgehen in Berlin ist der
Klima Volksentscheid nicht angenommen
worden das war doch eine demokratische
Entscheidung
richtig
ich weiß nicht was ich daraus ableitet
für letzte Generation
ich glaube schon dass es einen
Legitimation gibt für das was wir tun es
gibt das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts aus dem Jahr
2021 das sagt unsere Regierung bricht
die Verfassung ist nicht mehr auf dem
Boden der Verfassung mit sehr vielen
Klimaschutz gesetzten
und noch mal also es gibt glaube ich
immer Ziele wie zum Beispiel
Frauenrechte
das Frauen wählen gehen dürfen das stand
früher auch in keinem Gesetz das hatte
auch keine Mehrheit damals in England
weil es Frauen gar nicht wählen durften
und dann sind die so lange
Widerstand auf die Straße gegangen bis
sie das doofen und der Schutz unserer
Lebensgrundlagen ist die Voraussetzung
für Demokratie Menschenwürde Freiheit
alles was unsere Verfassung ausmacht und
ich leite daraus durchaus eine
Legitimität ab wie kann man sagen ist
nicht aber da hat man halt einen
unterschiedliches Weltbild und
noch mal vielleicht zu den Punkt zu
diesem Tempolimit das ist doch ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Steinen die so
ich glaube es wurde eben eingeblendet
4,9 Millionen Tonnen CO2 stellen sich
mal vor wir nehmen alle Menschen in
Deutschland wurden jetzt CO2 Ausstoß auf
das reduzieren was soll der Durchschnitt
hat das sind diese 11 Formen das heißt
die obersten dritte müssten relativ viel
reduzieren und hätten das Leben Standard
die die ich
dann hätten wir 30 % der notwendigen
Einsparung die wir machen müssen schon
erreicht ohne dass irgendwer unter der
neuen Heizung echt muss ohne das andere
dein Auto verkaufen muss und und und die
Leute müssen ein bisschen genutzt aber
werden die jetzt ihren überreichtum
grünen aber ich glaube das ist
vertretbar dafür dass wir am Ende und
wieder was zu essen und trinken haben
ganz kurz alleine schon mal anknüpfen
und zwar der
Zuschauer der sich da eingebracht hat
hat er von dem verlorenen Volksentscheid
gesprochen und ich glaube das ist ähm so
ein Mythos der sich immer stärker bildet
der volkszeit das muss man glaube ich
sagen da haben mehr Menschen zugestimmt
als ihn abgelehnt haben das Forum war
der entscheidende Faktor es haben über
400.000 Menschen gesagt okay wir
brauchen ambitionierte Klimaschutzziele
für Berlin ambitioniertere als bislang
aufgeschrieben ist sogar einige sagen
Ziele die wir gar nicht erreichen können
trotzdem haben so viele Menschen gesagt
also mehr Menschen als abgelehnt haben
das brauchen wir
ich will es jetzt nicht kleinreden dass
es Coron mich nicht funktioniert hat für
diesen Volksentscheid aber wenn man sagt
der Volksentscheid ist gescheitert oder
dass das wäre sogar noch zutreffend aber
hatte keine Mehrheit oder so das glaube
ich wird dem Bild was ich da ergeben hat
in Berlin nicht ganz gerecht und ich
glaube das was jetzt hier in versucht
auszudrücken ist wir haben Gesetze in
der in unserer Republik die sind
demokratisch entstanden die werden
vielfältig gebrochen immer wieder und
immer wieder und eben auch das
Klimaschutzgesetz wird dort ist dort
tangiert vorkommen gerichtet und Gesetze
kann man brechen es gibt ganz wenige
Gesetze die man nicht sprechen kann das
Naturgesetze und das ist eben genau
unser Problem dass wir eine Situation
haben wo Menschen gemacht hat
Klimawandel menschengemachte Klimakrise
Stück für Stück Raum greift in unserem
Leben unser Leben immer beschwerlicher
wird durch diese Klimakrise weiß stimmt
ja es geht nicht im Klimaschutz Vorgaben
die man erreichen will geht darum unser
Leben
Selbstwert zu halten unsere
Lebensgrundlagen zu erhalten und das
wird tangiert durch die Naturgesetze
durch Physik wenn man so will durch
Physik Chemie und so weiter und da
müssen wir darauf eingehen und wenn da
unsere Gesetze nicht ausreichen dann
kommt inzwischen das Verfassungsgericht
sagten und daher und sagt hey
liebe Politik Liebe Demokratie Liebe
bitte BürgerInnen und Mitbürger des
Naturgesetz das können wir selbst nicht
mal als Gericht ignorieren das müssen
wir mit unserem Recht in Einklang
bringen und wenn da das
Klimaschutzgesetz der großen Koalition
eher dämlich ausreichend war dann muss
das angepasst da muss das korrigiert
werden so das ist ja der Hintergrund und
wenn man das
sich zu eigen macht wenn man das liebt
wenn man das annimmt dann weiß man auch
dass wir auf diesem Planeten halt
gewissen Gesetzmäßigkeiten folgen müssen
und wenn man da als Menschen gegen
verstoßen dann kann man das vielleicht
eine Zeit lang machen aber da gibt es
halt eine physikalische eine chemische
Reaktion zu und dann müssen wir damit
umgehen und das ist jetzt eben diese
Klimakrise die uns das Leben halt immer
schwerer machen wird wenn wir darauf
nicht adäquat reagieren und deswegen ist
es so richtig da die Energiewende
voranzutreiben die
Verkehrswende voranzutreiben das muss
nicht immer einhergehen mit oder das
muss nicht einhergehen mit
Wohlstandsverlust das muss aber
einhergehen mit einer Änderung
in der Herstellung der Energie in der
Bereitstellung von Mobilität in ja auch
im heizen ja wir werden da keinen Sektor
aussparen können auch nicht das Heizen
aber stimmt natürlich es gibt noch
Möglichkeiten dort auch schneller
voranzukommen und natürlich muss man
diese Möglichkeiten besonders ergreifen
ja wir haben es gerade gehört da geht's
ums Heizen da geht's um die
mobilitätswende da geht's um die
Energiewende das sind aber alles
Bereiche die man vor allem in der
Politik vorantreibt und dazu haben wir
noch eine Frage auf Youtube bekommen von
Andreas dietzler an sie hätte ihn wäre
es nicht sinnvoller mit ihren Anliegen
eine Partei zu gründen und die Leute mit
Aufklärung und Fakten zu überzeugen so
dass es in der Form Demokratie einen
Wandel gibt weil demokratisch ist das ja
so nicht
und genau das
naja in der leicht abgeänderten Form
ordern wir ja ich glaube es gibt die
Grünen die Grünen machen einen guten
Jobs wurden ja auch in verschiedenen
Ländern kleinere klimaparteien gegründet
unsere Forderung als letzte Generation
ist ja derzeit der gesellschaftsrat also
ein Bürgerrat zum Thema Klima der die
Frage stellt wie steigen wir bis 20 30
sozialgerecht aus dem fossilen aus und
gesellschaftsrat das bedeutet 160
Menschen aus ganz Deutschland
Arme reiche junge alte gebildet
ungebildet und und und und repräsentativ
zusammengesetzt werden ausgelost
zusammengesetzt und bekommen eine Reihe
von Sitzungen
die notwendige Unterstützung die Sie
brauchen von Experten von
Leuten aus der Wissenschaft von
PolitikerInnen um einen guten Plan um
gute Maßnahmen zu erarbeiten wie wir
diese Ziele erreichen können unsere
Lebensgrundlagen zu schützen und diese
Vorschläge für Maßnahmen gehen dann an
den Bundestag und können dann da
beschlossen werden oder auch nicht aber
der Vorteil ist zum einen dass diese
Menschen nicht sich darum Sorgen müssen
wiedergewählt zu werden und zum anderen
haben diese Maßnahmen Vorschläge eine
große Legitimität weil sie wie gesagt
von Menschen aus allen Bereichen
Deutschlands vorgeschlagen wurden
entwickelt wurden und das fordern wir
das so ein gesellschaftsrat eingesetzt
wird und der uns nach vorne bringt diese
vermeintliche fortschrittskoalition die
wir gerade haben sPD FDP die Grünen sind
unendlich zerstritten wir haben jetzt
schon ganz viel gehört und wir kommen
nicht so richtig nach vorne es gibt kein
Fortschritt und wir als letzte
Generation glauben so ein
gesellschaftsrat könnte diesen
Fortschritt bringen und er ist das
demokratische vorstellen kann weil
darin diesen Mini Deutschland
repräsentiert ist
gehört die Forderungen ist oder dies
Ziel was erreicht werden soll ist bis
2030 sozialverträglich aus den fossilen
Energien auszusteigen wie Realist wie
realistisch ist denn das was ihrer Sicht
ich würde sagen wir müssen jeden Tag
einen Schritt und Mix großen Schritt
machen dann schauen wir mal wie wir das
hinbekommen 20 30 ist jetzt
gerade in Berlin
einmal durchgerechnet worden und dort
haben viele Menschen gesagt also viele
expertenexperten gesagt das ist sehr
ambitioniert für Deutschland ist das
bestimmt nicht minder ambitioniert ähm
ich würde so ein gesellschaftsraten
Klima Bürgerrat wie auch immer man das
Kind
vollständig begrüßen um dann eben auch
einmal unter die Menschen durch das zu
diskutieren oder diesen Ausschnitt der
Menschen zu diskutieren welche Maßnahmen
denn da akzeptiert werden und was man
bereit ist einem welchen Weg man bereit
ist zu gehen Demokratie muss immer
beweisen auch gerade entlang von von
Krisen also es hilft ja nichts wenn man
eine gute Staatsform haben wo ähm oder
wir keine bessere ähm kennen wo eben gut
verhandelt wird wo man immer auf Konsens
kommt wenn die Krisen wird nicht tja
gelöst werden und ich glaube dass diese
Demokratien der wir leben Krisen lösen
kann und das muss sie beweisen und
gerade wenn solche Debatten jetzt
aufkommen die Forderungen nach
gesellschaftsrat oder Bürgerrat dann ist
das auch immer eine Anzeige dass da eine
Erwartung gerade nicht erfüllt wird von
der Demokratie und deswegen ist das auch
so eine Forderung nützlich ich komme mir
persönlich aus dem Osten Deutschlands
wir hatten hier 89,90 runde Tische da
sind auch in Österreich Kreis von
Menschen zusammengekommen um eben eine
große Krise
eine große Krise eine große Chance
wahrzunehmen auf eben Demokratie und ich
glaube dass wir jetzt nicht minder an
der Stelle sind dass wir schauen müssen
wie kriegen wir diese Klimakrise adäquat
und zwar nicht nur rhetorisch sondern
auch im Handeln gestellt und eben gelöst
dabei hänge ich mich immer nicht an
Jahreszahlen auf sondern
so umso größer der erste Schritt ist
umso mehr Zeit kann man sich hinten raus
lassen deswegen es geht doch eigentlich
im Tonnen und nicht im Jahre und CO2 ähm
und da
es gibt viele die von solchen Maßnahmen
die jetzt auch kein weh tun weil die
Menschen kommen dann auch mit einem
kleinen Auto wenn Sie unbedingt ein Auto
brauchen von A nach B wenn man dann Bus
und Bahn noch entsprechend nicht nur
einfacher und günstiger machen sondern
auch noch viel attraktiver im Sinne von
das ist eben viel mehr Angebote dort
gibt dann dann glaube ich dass auch
viele Menschen sagen ich brauche gar
kein eigenes Auto rein eigenes Auto ist
ja durchaus auch anstrengen man muss es
anmelden muss warten man muss es fliegen
man muss Steuern dafür sein so das ist
man muss den Führerschein machen das ist
ja er fällt ja alles nicht vom Himmel
und deswegen da müssen wir die Kurve
kriegen um endlich da ähm ja die die
Menschen die Menschen mitnehmen die
Angebote zu machen wo man auch gerne
sich klimafreundlich Klima
klimafreundlich verhält
dann kommen wir da auch da kriegen wir
doch noch die Kurve aber dafür muss es
in der Politik muss es im Parlament muss
es in der Regierung die Anstrengung von
allen sein die dort werkeln die dieser
Klimakrise entgegenzutreten weil das ist
ja keine also Klimaschutz oder Haltung
der Lebensgrundlagen ist ja nun keine
alleinige Aufgabe von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen sondern das adressiert alle und
das muss auch alle interessieren ja und
in verschiedenen Wahlprogrammen von
allen Parteien steht da immer irgend so
ein Satz mit der Haltung der
Lebensgrundlagen drinne und diesmal
ernst zu nehmen da wirklich auf das Ziel
zuzugehen äh das fehlt mir über einigen
Parteien auch sehr stark und da müssen
wir noch mehr Mitstreiter Mitstreiter in
dem Parlamenten aber auch jenseits der
Parlamente finden um da voranzukommen
das war so am Ende des Horizont steht
die da die Wünsche die sind auf beiden
Seiten gar nicht so weit voneinander
entfernt der Weg wie man da hinkommt
aber durchaus hätte vielen Dank für
diese Diskussion
ich gucke zum Schluss dieser Diskussion
noch mal in die Kommentare und darauf
was ihr so zu dem Thema denkt das ist ja
einfach ein Thema was gerade gefühlt
ganz Deutschland spaltet hier schreibt
jemand ich kann es absolut verstehen
wenn Autofahrern die Nerven durchgehen
oder diese Art des Protests ist
kompletter Quatsch und erzählt einfach
gar nichts was genau geht mit dem Kleben
einher gibt es direkte Gespräche mit der
Politik und dann liest man aber auch die
Grünen machen nicht genug oder können
nicht genug machen und die Aktionen von
der sogenannten letzten Generation sind
lächerlich und hier gibt's aber auch
Kommentare die sagen wichtig dass die
letzte Generation das macht nur so
schafft man Aufmerksamkeit ihr seht
diese besondere Art des Protests die
vielen nicht gefällt die Klimaziele all
das sind Themen die ziemlich
unterschiedliche Reaktionen hervorrufen
deswegen bin ich mir sicher dass wir
hier bei ZDF heute live auch noch das
ein oder andere Mal darüber sprechen
vielen Dank für Ihre Input und für eure
Fragen und vielleicht bis bald